designed by miese Van Der Roe in the
1950s this house was a radical departure
from the ornay decorative styles that
dominated architecture for centuries
instead the Farnsworth House embraced
Simplicity functionality and minimalism
one of the key ways in which the
Farnsworth House broke new ground was
through the use of materials well the
use and the expression of Steel and
glass especially in a house was pretty
revolutionary at the time the expansive
Glass Walls allowed for uninterrupted
views of the surrounding landscape
blurring the boundary between inside and
outside the challenge the conventional
idea of a house instead of a series of
separate rooms the house was designed as
a single continuous space with different
areas defined by furniture and other
elements well you could probably say
that the Farnsworth House is one of the
icons of modernist architecture and a
testament to the power of design to
challenge Inspire and transform the
status quo